foreign
I remember this one time over the summer
that I was cutting hair and I seen
a couple
and they were standing about 10 feet
from me and instantly I seen they were
out of place a couple feet in front of
them they see one guy shooting another
guy up in the neck they see people
literally laying in the gutter
smoking crack out in the open shooting
up out in the open you know and this was
summertime you're seeing literally holes
in people's arms and people's legs
and this is what they're witnessing they
were from Lebanon PA which is about two
hours from Kensington and they were
looking for their son
they had never heard of Kensington they
had never seen any of the videos on
YouTube
they had never seen any of the stories
on the news I started looking at things
now and I was like damn imagine if I'm
them what they're seeing for the first
time I'm seeing people that look like
they're dead
you know everybody nodded off in awkward
positions that you damn near have to be
a contortionist to get into you're
seeing that every so many feet
all the needles
people walking with blood running down
their neck it's hard to describe and
it's hard to fathom
and as a parent as a father I instantly
related to them
I said damn imagine if I never knew
anything about Kensington
Ground Zero of our local heroin epidemic
lies in the heart of Philadelphia's
Kensington section Kensington the drugs
were the motive for a shooting in
Kensington this morning they're drug
users from all over line the streets and
makeshift area in Kensington about this
Haven for drug addicts Don heroin in
Kensington Ground Zero for
Philadelphia's Irwin epidemic he's on
the front lines of the nation's heroin
epidemic with evidence if battles lost
scattered like wings that's big results
in Kensington a residents struggling
with drug addiction May soon have a
place to safely inject themselves drug
abuse in Kensington is just not hard to
find opioid crisis is far from over
thank you
[Music]
I'll face that way I don't want to get
nobody in the background uh
my name is Frank Rodriguez I was born in
Brooklyn New York
I have a YouTube channel called morals
over money and through that channel my
hopes are to humanize addicts people
that deal with addiction people that
deal with homelessness
always
this is always busy
this this really don't change too much
so I'm originally from New York I um I
grew up in Brooklyn
the area I grew up at the time was just
like this it was a called the south side
and uh it was just like this it was an
open-air drug Market you know my family
was my mother and my father were both
addicts
um pretty much everybody in the
household was addicts addicted to heroin
at the time
I moved to Pennsylvania when I was about
eight years old
and um I ended up coming to Philadelphia
for the first time and
probably two thousand
excuse me
1990 maybe like 94.
and when I when I ended up coming out
here I was in the midst of my addiction
um and I picked up for the first time uh
soon after my mother was killed in a car
accident
I had to identify her body on on
you know that day at the coroner's
office
and I try to go to sleep that night and
I couldn't sleep next night couldn't
sleep I saw a family member that was a
nurse
recommended that I take something
to calm my nerves and tell me look it's
common you know when people are
experiencing grief or a loss that's what
they do
so I took it put me to sleep good
that eventually led to
taking Percocets Percocets eventually
led to you know doing heroin
thank you
[Music]
storing this in his hand
meat on his neck
all bags around him oh
you all right man
you gotta get up off the ground brother
got you sneaker I you over there
[Music]
look like you got a couple bags right
there next to you too
when I initially moved out of Kensington
um it was
the day after I heard my oldest
daughter's heartbeat me and her mother
went to the doctor
I heard my daughter's heartbeat for the
first time and I started crying
I just got high just shot up right
before we went to the appointment
I realized that very shortly
there was a little baby that was going
to be coming into that world
that was relying on me and if she would
have came that day
I would have been highly unfit to be her
father
she didn't get a choice to say
I want my dad to be a drug addict I want
my dad to have a to have an addiction to
heroin
and I realized that things quickly had
to change
literally that night we left the doctor
appointment I packed up my stuff
and left my apartment I told myself I
gotta I have to leave if I don't leave I
might not be alive to leave the next
time that I want to
do
and then he got it he was happy yeah
in 2016 in Kensington I would go do
haircuts for the addicts and the
homeless and the less fortunate and then
when I was using drugs
I was at
you know some of the lowest points of my
life I feel like that helps me to relate
to people a little bit more than others
maybe so when I go to Kensington and I
give somebody a haircut I'm not worried
about touching them and I'm not worried
about how dirty they are I'm not worried
about if they stink
I'm not worried about if they're nodding
off
um I still see a human being under there
because I know at one time that was me
I was very strict on not letting them
take pictures or video or anything and
one day one of the individuals did like
a Facebook live
and the person I was cutting that
person's mother ended up reaching out to
me later on that night she hadn't seen
her son in four years she didn't know if
he was alive or dead she said that was
the first sighting of him first that she
knew he was okay
she asked me to please continue to do it
so you know I was like nobody wants to
be seen in this type of condition
and then I started to realize that I was
sort of looking at it selfishly
and there was family members back home
that are thinking every single night
going to sleep not knowing if their son
or their loved one is Dead Alive what
type of condition they are and that's
originally how I started
doing the the videos and the interviews
it it was by accident
it's a life in Kensington it's very
cheap
people the addicts there they're not
viewed as human beings they're looked at
as part of the landscape
I often try to come up with words or a
way to express Kensington to describe to
people just exactly what it is hell
hell like a war zone
like a third world country kind of thing
kensington's going to eat them up and
spit them out literally hell suffering
ugly
all of that
it's sad
they're gonna come back
torn it's just chaos it's it's so
like it's so far out of the realm of
what
we think normal life is supposed to be
you see people with blood running down
their neck all the time it looks like
they got bit by a vampire didn't you see
them running around with a needle in
their hand Point uncovered in Kensington
that's you know that's that's normal
I see the drug addiction I see the drug
dealing I see the violence
I see the poverty
but I think most of all I see pain
you know that that's what you see there
you see
I think Humanity at its lowest
me overdosing is what
made me get clean and changed my life
you know I I had a bad weekend I
relapsed a single use I used one time I
sniffed a bag
and I woke up in the hospital three days
later
for me that's why I see people
overdose and I see people stretched out
and laid out and I want to go there and
just be like yo you all right because
you don't never know
you know that that's all it took for me
to completely change my life 180 degrees
um
you know where maybe there's
there's other people that
I like that also you know and maybe not
but
foreign
[Music]